marijuana's basically catnip for people
it was gained increasing acceptance in
recent years in fact one small bright
spot on election night was pro marijuana
referenda passing in eight states a big
win for lovers of weed so we are really
excited I mean this is a huge victory
not just for Californians but for really
the country and the world everybody here
should be so excited by this it's a
little weird that those celebrations
happened the same night that Trump was
elected it's like celebrating your
baseball team winning on the deck of
this sinking Titanic bit of a mix back
today but still go Sox Yankees suck now
as it as it stands 44 states now have
some form of medical marijuana law and
eight have laws allowing recreational
use and that is good news the war on
drugs was futile expensive and imposed
overly harsh penalties especially on
African Americans who police data
suggests over four times more likely to
be arrested for marijuana possession
although interestingly white people are
a million times more likely to be
shocked by that statistic and this is
clearly no longer a fringe issue in 1969
a Gallup poll showed 12% favorite
legalization today it's 60% exactly
marijuana is something we've just all
gradually decided is okay like Mark
Wahlberg as a serious actor you know
what sure I've decided I'm fine with
that but the legality of marijuana is
actually much more fraught than you may
think in fact if you have marijuana
right now even if you are acting
completely legally according to your
state you may still be in serious
jeopardy and that's not your weeding
juice to paranoia talking you could lose
your home job or possessions Greg and
yeah I know I'm freaking the out of
any stoned viewer named Greg right now
but that is not a bad thing because this
story is genuinely worth worrying about
and let's begin with going back to why
marijuana is so heavily regulated in the
first place it was legal at the start of
the 20th century but anti-drug hysteria
fueled partly by racist stereotypes
about who was using it led to it being
gradually outlawed around the country
and naturally it was Richard Nixon the
Mozart of racially motivated lawmaking
who targeted it in his war on drugs for
rhesus that he was open about in
conversations he inexplicably recorded
[Music]
[Applause]
yes quick historical footnote do you
know who he's talking to there Billy
Bush yeah people just open up to that
guy
Oh Nixon Nixon signed the Controlled
Substances Act in 1970 and it's still in
effect today
marijuana is classified as a schedule 1
drug the highest classification
alongside heroin schedule 2 a step-down
features drugs like cocaine and
methamphetamine and marijuana it's not a
Schedule one any more than a hedge hog
is an apex predator you're not scaring
anyone Roland get a tattoo but that
federal law is constantly clashing with
new state laws and it's causing big
problems for instance legal marijuana
businesses have struggled to get bank
accounts because at the federal level
they are still seen as criminal
enterprises so if banks took their
deposits that could be considered money
laundering and this was meant that
businesses had to operate all cash 100%
of our revenue comes in cash this is
federal taxes that we pay in cash also
our payroll when we pay all 12 employees
they're getting envelopes of cash these
are state taxes that is a shitty way to
be forced to do business
on the suspicious scale cash stuffed
envelopes ranked somewhere between
unfilled hundreds dusted in white powder
and a wad of damp ones containing a
single pubic hair and if you are
wondering why he was talking about
paying his federal taxes yeah amazingly
under federal tax law you must declare
income even if the source of it is
illegal the tax code even has provisions
like if you receive a bribe included in
your income and if you steal property
you must report it's fair market value
which seems such an obvious trap to
catch criminals it's really been listed
on the form as this is a trap are you
really this stupid oh my god you're
filling out a federal form admitting
guilt aren't you you dumb dumb idiot
so marijuana businesses have all the tax
liabilities of other businesses but what
they don't get is one major advantage
the agency bars them from making most
normal business deductions you know you
could end up with a tax bill far more
than you you know any potential profit
you could ever make that's right you
can't deduct certain expenses and that
can mean that you pay double the amount
of tax that you would if you were
selling any other products and just
think about that that means the shop
where you bought your weed may pay
double the amount of taxes paid by the
shop where you ordered that shitty pizza
Greg yeah I'm talking to you again Greg
I told you this was important pay
attention
and it is not just businesses facing
difficulties its customers to just look
at Brandon Coates who is paralyzed from
a car accident as a teenager now he had
a prescription for medical marijuana but
he was fired from his job at the Dish
Network after he filed a drug test
what was it like for you when they said
we don't want you to work here anymore
well it was devastating I mean it's hard
enough for somebody like me to get a job
people look at me like they probably
don't think that I can do what I can you
know did you think because you had a
medical marijuana car that you had
license to go ahead and use it well it
was always under the impression that we
had passed a law and that we had made it
legal yeah it's frankly understandable
that he thought he was doing nothing
wrong the state had given him a
licensed to use medical marijuana
legally and yet he got fired anyway and
also he couldn't turn to the Americans
with Disabilities Act for help because
that is a federal law and it doesn't
protect marijuana use all of which is
pretty frustrating that's like driving
exactly the speed limit and getting
pulled over by a cop who tells you sorry
the federal speed limit is three and the
legal age to drive is 62 and also you
have to be drunk surprised you're
under arrest now and even if you are
only dealing with your government at the
state level decades of enforcing
anti-drug laws can result in local
officials making big mistakes as to
michigan parents
one of whom treated his epileptic
seizures with marijuana discovered in
steven maria green of lansing helplessly
watched as their infant daughter bree
was taken from their care the reason
given the state sanctioned medical
marijuana users home was too dangerous
for their six-month-old because of the
plants inside it would place our
residents at a higher rate of armed
robbery and therefore was an imminent
danger for my child to be removed that
is just completely absurd if you have
valuable items in your home we might
take your children and i will say that
is gonna add some real excitement to the
prices rights from now on I really want
that entertainment center but I love my
kids it sorry Tommy daddy's going
for the plasma screen it's a dream son a
dream of mine and look I know that some
people will say well hold on the medical
efficacy of marijuana needs a lot more
study and that is true the problem is
it's very difficult to do that because
again federal laws are standing in the
way to study marijuana you need approval
from three different federal agencies
which can take years in fact
one scientist was forced to wait six
years just to begin studying its effects
on PTSD which is a long time I frankly
wouldn't blame her if she just said
it I'm studying dust chocolate during
sex help red wine make you lose weight
at least at least that way I'll get to
go on the Today Show
if you are conducting a federally
approved study on marijuana you can only
get it from one place dr. mahmoud al
solely oversees the University of
Mississippi's marijuana project its
mission to aid law enforcement and
produce pop for federal study mostly
related to addiction for all intents and
purposes you're the government's sole
producer of marijuana records it's true
the sole source of government sanctioned
marijuana is that guy at the University
of Mississippi
so please update your stereotypes about
the University of Mississippi which I
believe is the official slogan of the
University of Mississippi and what
researchers wait for marijuana to study
whether it helps with PTSD plenty of
veterans will tell you it absolutely
does take Danny Belcher he is a Vietnam
vet who'd be prescribed a great deal of
medication for pain and depression but
as he told the Kentucky legislature in
2014 he found that when he tried
marijuana it started really helping him
I do have my bola pot in my house if I
wake up at night in that nightmare when
I'm wringing wet with sweat and I see
Cramer his dead body Rodriguez his dead
body if that nightmare gets a bad I
can't wake up I realize it's just a
nightmare I will light that pipe up I'll
be a criminal I'll go back to sleep
the next morning I will get up at 6
o'clock like I always do my four days a
week I go to the gym I run to help other
veterans I couldn't do that if I was on
him damn drugs the VA had me on exactly
so for all the talk you hear of
marijuana being a gateway drug in his
case that gateway led to peaceful sleep
rigorous exercise and community service
pretty nice gate it turns out
nice one to walk through if you get the
chance now you may have noticed that he
said he's acting like a criminal there
which is a little odd because Kentucky
actually has a medical marijuana law on
the books but these shortcomings of that
law touch on many of the reasons why
legal marijuana can actually be a bit of
a gray area for a start Kentucky's law
has many
striction see only applies to one
marijuana product and it requires a
written order or a prescription and that
is a real problem because under federal
law it is technically illegal for any
doctor to write you a prescription for
marijuana now so most states that they
get around that by just calling for a
recommendation or a certification which
doctors can give you but even if
Kentucky's law did that if Danny went to
his doctors at the VA they couldn't give
him anything because they're a federal
hospital and federal policy prohibits VA
doctors from even recommending marijuana
regardless of the state law and
regardless of their medical opinion
which again is a bit weird a doctor
shouldn't be ignored
because he recommends marijuana a doctor
should only be ignored because he is
televised we all agree on that we're all
on the same plates on that one I think
it gets worse even if Danny have a
private doctor and Kentucky rewrote its
law where would he get marijuana from
because Kentucky's law also neglected to
set up any system for legal marijuana
distribution so he'd have to obtain it
from somewhere else but where would he
do that
and how now he could have it shipped
right except no that would be a federal
crime but what if he flew to a state
where marijuana is completely legal and
just brought it back to Kentucky here's
the thing no again that is also a
federal crime could he drive to a
neighboring state to get what he needs
unfortunately no because two of those
states have total prohibitions on
marijuana and the rest don't currently
recognize out-of-state patients now if
you are thinking whoa hold on
could he train a carrier pigeon to carry
the pot from Colorado yes that's a good
idea and cool bird stamp but but as a
practical matter there no partly because
it's illegal and partly because you know
the birds will eat it on the way stop
flying and spend the whole night
giggling about how owls seem like they
have glasses but like don't have
and that's crazy right they don't know
but it's there right the point is if you
live in Kentucky despite that being a
law that ostensibly gives access to
medical marijuana there's virtually no
legal way for you to get it now things
fractionally improved so will the end of
the Obama administration because his
general attitude was essentially this we
still have federal laws that classify
marijuana as a illegal substance but
we're not going to spend a lot of
resources trying to turn back decisions
that have been made at the state level
on this issue what he's attitude to pot
was basically I'm not gonna hassle you
over this and unless you make me
essentially the same policy as a
security guard at a Dave Matthews
concert and his administration issued
guidelines in that spirits by the end of
his term it was actually a little easier
to study marijuana and for dispensaries
to get bank accounts but those
guidelines weren't permanent and that
could be a real problem because our new
Attorney General is jeff Sessions the
concept of golf expressed in man form
and he he's been pretty clear where he
stands on marijuana this is not an non
dangerous drug this drug is dangerous
you cannot play with it it's not funny
it's not something to laugh about and in
trying to send that message with clarity
that good people don't smoke marijuana
well Lady Gaga said she's addicted to it
and is not harmless okay Jeff but Lady
Gaga also said I believe that men and
women deserve to love each other equally
as well as touch me in the dark put your
hands all over my body parts so please
Jeff if you're going to live your life
according to Gaga quotes accept the
entire canon
listen I'm not saying there shouldn't be
laws that play sensible restrictions on
marijuana as there are with other
substances but our federal laws
desperately need to be brought up to
date and perhaps there is no clearer
sense of just how establishment that
view is becoming than this the cannabis
caucus is a bipartisan effort to protect
state marijuana laws and blow out
outdated federal prohibitions on weed
believe it or not these are the guys
pushing for legalized pot in Congress
yes there is now a cannabis caucus in DC
and it's co-chaired by these four narcs
and if even an 83 year old Republican
from Alaska has come around on this
issue then it's probably time for our
laws to catch up and there are a bunch
of ideas out there one bill proposed
just this week would remove marijuana
from the Controlled Substances Act and
officially renamed the ATF the Bureau of
Alcohol Tobacco marijuana
Firearms and Explosives which does
really make sense just get all the
awesome stuff together in one place
in fact why not keep going and making it
the Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco marijuana
firearms explosives monster trucks
motorcycle jump and sick-ass leather
jackets with Tigers on them and by the
way that jacket is even sicker in person
this is my jacket
this was me this morning this is an
actual $6,000 Gucci jacket stupid enough
to buy one of these it's worthless now
I just made your jacket uncool and
worthless by wearing it but that bill is
just one proposal fixing all of these is
a huge undertaking marijuana laws affect
everything from environmental
regulations to international treaties
and ideally we should also go back and
expunged records of people convicted of
low-level marijuana offenses in the past
and all of this I know is a lot of work
which is why we should really start
right now because I would argue that it
is absolutely worth it for people like
Brandon Coates and for people like Danny
Belcher and perhaps most of all for Greg
who has been freaking the out this
whole time I can see you Greg and I can
hear your thoughts